[Music]
Welcome back to the most news in the
morning. 37 minutes past the hour right
now. A proposal to build a mosque and
Islamic cultural center near ground
zero, generating a lot of heat at a
hearing in New York City. Opponents want
to give landmark status to the
150year-old building, which would
essentially prevent the mosque and
center from being built. We're going to
hear from both sides of the emotional
debate today. Joining us, Pamela Geller,
executive director of Stop Islamization
of America and a a blogger with uh with
Atlasshrugs.com. Also, Ibrahim Remy with
the Muslim American Society. Thanks to
both of you for being with us this
morning. So, Pamel, you've become an
outspoken critic of this project in
general. Um uh the people who are behind
it say that what they want it to do is
improve relations, to have it be a place
of tolerance and a multicultural center.
In fact, do you not believe uh what
they're saying about what the um motive
is behind building this? Well, they have
been dishonest. Uh first they said it
was a mosque, then they said it was a
prayer center, which is a mosque.
They've been very shady about the
funding. We don't know where the funding
is coming from. Uh the imam has
advocated for tolerance and yet in his
book he advocates for the Sharia Islamic
law which is radically intolerant. Um
they say it's for outreach. Why there? I
mean, are you against a mosque being
built in general in New York City or at
this location? Absolutely not. We are
absolutely not against that. We believe
that that building is a war memorial. A
large piece of the plane fell onto the
roof, crashed through that building and
damaged it. It's a part of American
history. The largest attack, Islamic
attack on America in the history of
America. That should be a war memorial.
And that building is 152 years old,
designed by an architect who was a
pioneer in his day. His buildings have
been landmarked and it should be given
landmark status. That's Daniel Daniel
Badger. It's a it's a cemetery. We feel
that it's a cemetery and that it's
sacred ground and the dead should be
honored. And if it was really outreach,
then why is the majority of Americans
against it? Why is the majority of New
Yorkers against it? Where is the
outreach? Why is there not sensitivity
to how uh the the uh Muslims of
conscience and Americans feel about
this? Well, let me ask Abraham about
this. what is your take on uh the
proximity which is what has generated a
lot of the controversy about this
center? I think there is a a great deal
of pain still residually as as a result
of the criminal attacks on 911 but it
was not an Islamic attack. It was a
criminal attack. There are two things
I'd like to mention. The first is that
Muslims like other people in America
have first amendment rights in terms of
freedom of religion. But the second more
important thing is that we reject the
notion of collective guilt. We are not
collectively guilty for actions that are
taken by some people in the name of
Islam. Further, I think it's very clear
that the Cordoba Institute and a number
of Muslims in the United States are
really seeking to take a different way
of establishing new relationships with
America and and a new set of
relationships with the people of the
United States and this is an ideal way
to do that. 600 feet from not from from
the the biggest terror attack in US
history on US soil is the best way to do
it. I mean, I think that that that a lot
of the concern is the proximity to
ground zero, not necessarily the
building of a center. Well, well, there
are numerous memorials to people who
were killed in that attack. And so,
let's not try to conflate that idea or
that that notion into the idea of
Muslims having the right to have a
mosque. I mean, we're not trying to say
that people should uh should should be
compelled to believe in Islam. What we
believe is that Muslims have a
legitimate role to play in in the social
fabric of this country. we are part of
the uh interfaith mosaic of the United
States. But more than that, I think this
particular group of people in the
Cordoba Institute can do a huge amount
of good not only for Muslims in in New
York, but also for for interfaith
relations throughout the country. And
Pamela, I want to ask you about that.
There are 6 to 800,000 Muslims just in
Manhattan alone. And uh you did talk
about the polling. The polling is
interesting because when you take New
York City as a whole, uh according to
the Quinnipak poll, you can say actually
yes uh that the majority are against it.
But then when you break down Manhattan
itself, only 36% of people that were uh
that were in that poll are actually
against it. So is there really as as big
of an outcry about where this is going
to be built as uh some opponents are
making it out to be? Uh absolutely. Uh
this was an attack on America. It was
not a criminal attack. It was inspired
by jihad. There have been close to
16,000 Islamic attacks since 911 across
the world. What is being done to address
the ideology that inspires jihad? They
are inspired by the last book repentance
uh which commands jihad. If that that's
where the outreach is. But if you're
taking issue with radical Islam, why are
why does the Cordoba House fall into
that in your opinion? We are we are
asking Muslims to be sensitive to our
pain to our grief. The 9/11 families I
we organized a rally stop Islamization
of America organized a rally close to
10,000 people showed up. I mean there's
What does that mean by the way? I was
just curious about I mean some people
would say that's a loaded phrase. What?
stop Islamization in America. We believe
that um Islam should be westernized,
that America should not be Islamicized.
We don't believe in mosqueing the
workplace. We don't believe in
introducing Muslim prayer into public
schools. When you hear this, what what
goes through your head? Well, not just
the the term Islamophobia, but also,
frankly, a a kind of collective
intolerance that is really not conducive
to the spirit of what we're trying to do
as Muslims in America. I also have to
say that respectfully, Muslims were also
victimized by that attack. Muslims died
in that attack. They died at the
Pentagon. Uh there there are Muslims
right now in Congress. There are Muslims
in the national security system. There
are Muslims um in in the military who
would vehemently disagree with the idea
that we don't have a right to be a
represented part of the American
multiffaith mosaic. And we are here and
we've been here since before the US was
established as even as a republic. We're
part of the United States. Uh it's it's
highly insulting to call uh what we do
Islamophobic. Uh, frankly, uh, you could
make the counterargument for freedom
phobic. Uh, the the Muslim American
society is the public face of the Muslim
Brotherhood. Uh, I do not want to get
That's absolutely untrue. You should you
should know that. No, it's a it was
established by the Muslim Brotherhood as
a public face in the late in the late
80s. Absolutely not. I I urge people to
we don't have to debate that now. I
prefer to stay on the mosque, but I urge
people to look into it. Um, but to to to
pointing out dishonesty and subversion
is not bigotry and hatred. And I have no
problems. I love Muslims. I have no
problem with Muslims. But to build a
13story mega mosque on the cemetery on
the site of the of the largest attack in
American history, I think it's
incredibly insensitive. Do you believe
Pamela when she says she loves Muslims?
God knows what's in her heart. I know
that her words have been inflammatory.
They've been insulting. They have cast
dispersions on an organization that is
that is an American organization that's
legitimately part of 55 uh uh
communities in 30 states in the United
States that does great work around youth
development and charity and and and and
raising the level of the political
participation. Is there common ground?
Is there common ground of building this
perhaps in a would you agree to this
being built somewhere in in New York
that you could specifically say that
just wouldn't be at this location? Well,
listen. At this at this location, why
not if you're gonna have a mosque, why
not have I'm saying this exact project
swimming pool and a tennis court
synagogue and a church and a Hindu not
that what what Cordoba House is saying
they want to build. Would you be okay
with that 10 blocks away?
Listen, I have no problem with mosques.
Uh, one a mosque looking down on the
cemetery that of ground zero is
problematic. If it is outreach, why not
have a church also in the building and a
synagogue and a Buddhist temple and a
seek? I mean, if it's really truly
multicultural. I mean, the 92nd Street Y
doesn't have a synagogue. They equated
to that. The YW.C.A. doesn't have a
church. So, what we're going to find out
is whether or not this landmark ruling
comes down and whether or not that makes
a difference uh in the plans. But I want
to thank both of you for coming today,
for having a civil discussion about
this. I know that there are a lot of
emotions on every side. Pamela Geller
and Abraham Ramy. Thank you. Thank you,
Drew. Interesting stuff.
We are working on something that could
be very big. Big announcement coming out
of the Sarah Palin family. We hope to
have it nailed down right after this
break.